[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like the answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross
vice president of evangelism for amazing
facts hello friends how about an amazing
fact on June 21 1963 marine pilot Cliff
judkins was refueling in air on his way
from California to Hawaii when the
shuttle valve on his f8 crusader fighter
jet failed causing the tanks to overflow
spilling fuel all over his plane flames
quickly engulfed his jet and Judkins
realized that he needed to eject as soon
as possible so he tucked in his legs and
pulled eject to handle but nothing
happened he then pulled the backup
firing handle and receipt but still
nothing his only choice now was an
old-fashioned bailout no one had ever
tried bailing from an f8 crusader before
but with a quick prayer he manually
opened the canopy and at 220 knots and
15,000 feet he was quickly sucked out of
the cockpit his troubles however were
far from over when he pulled his
parachute the little pilot chute
deployed but the main parachute remained
an open
Judkins fell nearly 3 miles straight
down into the Pacific striking the water
at over 100 miles per hour amazingly
survived with two broken ankles a
fractured pelvis and a collapsed lung
what helped his survival however was an
event that occurred in his life four
years earlier after a car accident
Judkins had his spleen removed during
emergency surgery and if it had not been
removed based on the angle of impact
into the water it would have most
certainly ruptured and would have caused
his death
did you know friends that there is
another kind of surgery that can save
your life not only now but for eternity
stay tuned for more
as amazing facts brings you this edition
of Bible answers live you're listening
to Bible answers live honest answers to
your Bible questions this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
[Music]
four six three seven two ninety seven of
course it's a free phone call here in
North America one more time here's the
number eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven that'll bring you
here to the studio if you don't get
through right away just stay on the line
and we'll get to your call as soon as
possible this is actually a good time to
give us a call right now I see we have
about four lines that are still open
again that number is eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven well
before we get started with a program we
always like to ask God's blessing upon
our time together because we're talking
about the Bible
I mean order for us to understand the
Bible we need the Holy Spirit to lead us
so let's have a word of Prayer dear
father in heaven we thank you for the
opportunity that we have to open up your
word and study together this evening and
as we always do we invite the Holy
Spirit to come and speak to our hearts
our minds lead us into a clearer
understanding of the truth for Jesus
said you will know the truth and the
truth will set you free so that's our
desire this evening bless those who are
listening be with us here in the studio
in Jesus name
man we opened the program by telling a
rather remarkable story about a Marine
pilot by the name of Cliff judkins who
after ejecting from his plane didn't
have his main parachute open and relying
just simply on the pilot chute he fell
about three miles down into the Pacific
striking the water at more than a
hundred miles per hour and he survived
now he did have some broken bones but
probably the most amazing part of this
is a surgery that he had four years
before where he spleen was removed and
as they looked at the different angles
when he actually based on his injuries
how he struck the water head he still
had his spleen the doctors felt that
without a doubt ax would have ruptured
and would have caused his death so there
was an emergency emergency surgery that
he had that actually ended up saving his
life well of course all of us need to
have some kind of a spiritual surgery if
we wish to live for eternity the Bible
tells us in Ezekiel chapter 36 verse 26
I will give you a new heart I'll put a
new spirit within you I will take away
the heart of stone out of your flesh and
I will give you a heart of flesh so here
God is offering to give us a spiritual
heart transplant we need that kind of
change that change of heart that
spiritual surgery if we wish to live
forever now you might be wondering how
can I have that kind of experience maybe
you've heard about what God wants to do
maybe you recognize that you need to
have a spiritual change you need to have
this spiritual heart transplant how do
you have it what we do have a free book
that we'd like to make available to
anyone who is listening and also to our
friends who are listening on Facebook as
well the book is entitled three steps to
heaven and it deals with this very
important subject what must I do in
order to be saved how can I have that
spiritual change of heart it's free
we'll be happy to send it to anybody who
calls and asks now we're gonna give you
the resource phone line and that's the
number you want to call for our free
offer this evening the book once again
is entitled three steps to heaven and
the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that number one more time is eight
hundred eight
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book entitled three steps to
heaven I'll be happy to send that to
anybody who calls and asks well with
that we gonna go to the phone lines to
see what our calls are this evening and
the first caller that we have is Jack
listening from Pennsylvania Jack welcome
to the program hey yeah hi
hi welcome and your question this
evening pastor Doug this morning was
talking about something that you had to
be baptized in order to be saved okay
true well yes but let me explain it is
true that when somebody receives Jesus
as their personal Savior that they need
to follow through with the example that
Jesus said in being baptized baptism in
the New Testament is a symbol of death
to the old life a resurrection to the
new life it goes along with giving your
heart to Jesus and it's making a public
declaration that you're on God's side
you have left a path of sin and you are
committed to following Jesus and you're
choosing him as your personal Savior
so yes where it's possible without a
doubt you want to be baptized but there
are some cases where for example the
thief on the cross that was crucified
with Jesus we believe him to be saved
because jesus promised that he would
remember him when he came again he would
be with him in paradise
but of course the thief couldn't come
down from the cross and be baptized so
there are situations where somebody
maybe because of health or circumstances
as they're unable to be baptized
maybe it's near the end of their life
and they really receive Jesus as they
save you on their deathbed and
physically they're unable to be baptized
does that mean they can't be saved no
the baptism of Jesus takes their place
and his bathroom baptism is credited to
them as their baptism but where it is
possible for someone to be baptized that
is the appropriate thing to do it is a
public declaration of our allegiance to
Jesus and so yes baptism is necessary it
is important where it's possible
Oh does that make sense oh yeah I guess
so yeah so I your question why one
wouldn't want to be baptized or no I
just thought all these years that I was
saved but I guess not well you know what
I I wouldn't go to say that you aren't
saved I think God understands if we
asked for forgiveness but now that we do
know that that is God's will for us that
we make a public declaration of our
faith then it's only appropriate for us
to be baptized and so I'd encourage you
the next step in your journey your
Christian experience would probably be
finding a church that practices baptism
by immersion speaking with a pasta
expressing to him your concern that
you'd like to follow the example of
Jesus and be baptized and you know it's
one of the best decisions anyone can
make it's it becomes a point in your
experience where you look back and you
know at that point you made a public
declaration that you're living for Jesus
and it's such a wonderful experience the
Holy Spirit is there in a special way
when Jesus was baptized there was a
voice heard this is my beloved Son in
whom I am well pleased
so we know we are doing that which
pleases God when we make that decision
to be baptized so I would encourage you
to look into the jack you won't regret
it I promise you we do have a free book
dealing with the subject of baptism that
I think you'd enjoy reading
it's called baptism is it really
necessary again the book is called
baptism is it really necessary and we'll
be happy to send this to you jack or
anybody wanting to learn more about this
very important subject the number to
call is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven again that's 800
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the book called
baptism is it really necessary a next
caller that we have is Isaac listening
from Texas
Isaac welcome to the program good and
yourself have better method there thanks
all right
I had a friend who he goes to church too
but he keeps on giving me some ideas
that the world could maybe be flat I
personally don't really find it come to
much concerning but could it be biblical
that the world could be fat flat just
want to get your okay is it biblical if
the world is flat well the bible does
speak about four angels holding the four
corners of the earth you read that in
Revelation chapter 7 and people
sometimes conclude from that well maybe
the earth is flat almost like a square
and it's got four corners well that's
not what it means when it talks about
the four corners of the earth it's
simply referring to the four points of
the compass north south east and west if
you look at the scripture and what it
says about the earth it doesn't indicate
that the earth is flat matter of fact to
the country I'm looking at a verse here
and Isaiah chapter 40 verse 20 speaking
of God and it says it is he who sits
above the circle of the earth so there
it speaks of the earth being as a circle
being round so yeah the idea that the
earth is flat yeah I think we have
enough
we have enough plane circling the globe
we have enough satellites spinning up
above we have the space station that
goes around the earth I think it's
pretty clear that the earth is round
people have sailed around the earth so
the idea that the earth is some are flat
is it's not supported in Scripture and
it doesn't really it's not supported by
science either I'm good I just wanted to
hear you guys hear you explain a little
bit more absolutely not around good
question thanks for your call Isaac
again if you have a Bible question we
have a few lines that are open the
number to call here to the studio is 804
six three seven two nine seven it's 804
63 72 and 97 our next caller that they
have is Charles and he's listening from
Georgia Charles welcome to the program
thank you and your question this evening
now
I'm not still da but I know that Jesus
lead they'll ask him that you never find
any was only said he was there was
Mossad and he said no sign will be given
to the sign of Jonah Jonah was three
days and three nights in the fishing
really social the Son of Man be three
days and three nights in the heart of
the earth now had you days and three
nights and I replied no resurrection and
he was tired and Bible says he
unclassified illness the weekly Sabbath
the Bible says with a haughty Sabbath
alright well let me let me jump in there
Charles see if I can kind of help you
that's a good question what does it mean
the virtue referring to you is Matthew
chapter 12 verse 14 I'm gonna read it
for those who might be driving it might
not have their Bible in front of them it
says Jesus speaking for as Jonah was it
three days and three nights in the belly
of the great fish so also will the Son
of Man be three days and three nights in
the heart of the earth and people read
that and they read the phrase the heart
of the earth
and immediately they think well that
must be the tomb so how could Jesus be
in the tomb three days and three nights
if he was crucified on the preparation
day which was Friday and he rested in
the tomb on Sabbath and then he rose
from the dead the first out of the week
early hours in the morning on Sunday
well that's not exactly three nights
three days so what exactly does this
phrase mean well the heart of the earth
in Scripture does not mean the tomb does
not mean the grave Jesus referring to
the devil says he's the Prince of this
earth when it talks about Jesus being in
the heart of the earth Jesus started
bearing our sins on Thursday evening was
after the Last Supper with the disciples
in the upper room and then Jesus went to
the Garden of Gethsemane and that's
where he prayed father if it is possible
let this cup pass from me nevertheless
not my will but thy will be done Jesus
began to bear the weight of the sins of
the world
so that was Thursday evening and then of
course she was crucified on Friday and
Friday night he was in the tomb Saturday
night he was in the tomb he rose early
on Sunday morning so what we need to
understand is just the phrase the heart
of the earth the heart of the earth is
not the grave but it's in the Dominion
or the power of the devil
the devil is described as this prince of
this world and so God's the father's
protection was withdrawn from Christ he
began to feel the weight of the sins of
the world their Thursday evening now we
do have a book called the sign of Jonah
that gets into this in even more detail
and explain a lot more and I think you'd
enjoy reading that Charles all you're
left to do is just call and ask for the
book the number to call is 883 five six
seven four seven and pastor Doug
Batchelor wrote the book called the sign
of Jonah which deals with this very
passage in Matthew chapter 12 verse 40
one more time the number is 883 five six
seven four seven and asked for the book
the sign of Jonah we'll be happy to send
it to you Charles or anybody who calls
and asks our next caller that we have is
calling from looks like Milwaukee and
Wisconsin and can welcome to the program
hey thanks a lot how you doing doing
well and your question this evening yes
I have a question on John 14:27 where
says peace I leave with you and my peace
I give you I do give you as work ease
and another one is on Matthew 10:34
which jesus said do not assume that I
have come to bring peace to the earth I
have not come to bring peace but this
work we understand those two verses that
good question first of all it's two
different kinds of peace that Jesus is
referencing in Matt in John chapter 14
we'll start there when Jesus says peace
I leave with you my peace I give unto
you not as the world gives do I give you
so it's not a type of peace that you
might see in the world today or what the
world might consider peace then he says
let not your hearts be troubled
the peace that Jesus gives is the Peace
of knowing that we are forgiven
piece of knowing that we are accepted by
God the Peace of knowing that he is
taking care of us it is a piece the
Bible says that passes all understanding
you might see a Christian and they might
be circumference by all kinds of trials
and difficulties and yet they seem to
have a sense of peace even a sense of
joy in the midst of their trials and
people look at that and say man I just
don't understand how can this person
still seem to be at peace even in the
midst of all of these trials well that's
the kind of peace that Jesus is talking
about that he will give to those who
believe in him but we also know Jesus
says I have come to bring a sword not
peace well that's a different kind of
peace that he's referring to yes in this
life there have been many that have been
persecuted for their faith they have
been those who have been expelled from
their family or from their community for
the sake of the gospel and even the
disciples themselves because of their
faith in Jesus they experienced all
kinds of persecution and trials all of
the disciples were put to death died a
martyr's death other than John which is
probably the youngest of the 12
disciples but even in the midst of their
trials they still had this special peace
this heavenly peace that God gave them
so there's two kinds of peace that God
is referencing what Jesus is referencing
in these passages does that make sense
kam so two kinds of peace one that comes
from God that abides in your heart the
other piece is what we might experience
in the world meaning we have trials and
difficulties as do others and sometimes
the gospel does bring division it does
bring a turmoil it brings persecution
for those who are choosing to try and
follow God they might face opposition
for others so hopefully that helps good
question I've seen those two verses
before and folks have wondered about
that before if you have a Bible question
a phone line here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven and as mentioned before if you
don't get through right away
stay on the phone we'll try and get your
call on the air as soon as possible
our next call is Angela calling from
South Carolina
Angela welcome to the program let's try
that again there we go
Angela welcome to the program you there
yes I'm here hello hi there welcome oh
yeah my she asked if I knew the
scripture and I found the scripture that
my question is about okay and it's job
chapter one
it alright job chapter one and verse six
do you want me to read that now there
was a day when the sons of God came to
present themselves with the Lord and
Satan came also among them and I don't
really understand how that is when Satan
is evil and sin and it it's
confusing that he can exist in the
presence of God okay well good question
alright if you look at the context
what's happening here is well let me
back up a little bit more when God
created the earth in the beginning he
gave Adam dominion over the earth
meaning he was the representative of the
earth he was the caretaker of the earth
when Adam and Eve chose to disobey God
and chose to obey the devil in the form
of the serpent they're in the Garden of
Eden in essence Adam gave his Allegiance
or his authority over to the devil so
the devil now claims the earth as his he
claims to be the representative of the
earth
matter of fact Jesus even acknowledged
that to some degree when he was on the
earth and he said the prince of this
world comes and he finds nothing within
me and he is referencing the devil there
so when Adam sort of turned over
allegiance to the devil the devil said
well this is my kingdom this is my
domain and he claimed to be the
representative now there is this
gathering it talks about the sons of God
of the sons of God reference here are
probably the representatives of unfallen
worlds in Hebrews chapter 1 it
references that God made the world and
it uses the plural form so there are
other worlds with other created beings
of course we know the angels are also
created but there seems to be this
gathering possibly in heaven
but Satan shows up and he is claiming to
be the representative of this earth and
that's probably why he was tolerated why
he was allowed to be there and then of
course God says where did he come from
and Satan says Oh from walking up and
down on the earth in other words I've
been examining my kingdom and then God
said well have you noticed that there's
someone paraphrasing if you notice that
there's somebody in your kingdom that
really belongs in my kingdom his name is
Joe he's upright oh and Satan gets all
upset and says well the only reason he's
loyal to you is because all of the
blessings you've bestowed upon him and
God says no he's loyal to me because he
knows me and of course you have the
whole great controversy then played out
in the experience of job so Satan is the
representative of the earth at least he
was up until the point of the cross when
Jesus died on the cross and he rose from
the dead he is now our representative
before the Father and Jesus is gonna
come soon as king of kings and Lord of
lords so he has redeemed that which Adam
lost that's why in the New Testament
Jesus referred to as the second Adam so
the devil realizes he has but a short
time he has lost the kingdom he's lost
the earth it's gonna one day be Christ
and say he's going around like a roaring
lion seeking whom you may be our power
okay well thank you very much all right
well thank you for your call good
question our next caller that we have is
Randle listening from Canada Randle
welcome to the program well thank you so
much for having me thanks for calling
and your question this evening well my
question is this is there any scriptural
basis for believing that God can and
does restore marriages and Families my
wife divorced me four years ago and left
me and my youngest son and daughter went
with her and I've been praying now for
over four years for God to restore it
and I've had numerous people tell me
that I'm wasting my time and I have no
scriptural basis to base such things and
they have free will and I just need to
move on and forget about it
well no I think you're doing the right
thing
praying because the Bible says where
there is life there is hope
does God restore marriages and Families
absolutely yes there is their scriptural
basis for it like if there some
scriptural foundation a Biblical verse
or something that I can lean into and
and hold on to you know it's word that
that promises such things
sure I'll just give you one I'm just
thinking of one Old Testament passage
specifically talking about the family
that says behold I was saying you Elijah
the Prophet before the coming of the
Great and dreadful day of the Lord verse
6 is in Malachi chapter 4 verse 6 and he
will turn the hearts of the father's to
the children and the hearts of the
children to the father's so there is a
promise there that God is in the
business of restoring families restoring
marriages now of course there's always
freedom of choice involved and people
don't always make the right choices but
I would never stop praying for God to
perform a miracle because he can change
people's hearts if they'll but willing
and he can restore broken families and
broken marriages so I'll pray for your
kids pray for your wife ask the Lord to
do what he can to reveal himself to them
and through that experience try and draw
the family back together God is the one
who created marriage in the beginning
and it's the devil is doing everything
he can to destroy marriage to us
represent marriage and to tear apart the
family so you know when you pray and you
ask that this is the will of God that he
restore the family so I would keep
praying about that don't get discouraged
claim God's promises and and hold on to
them okay thank you alright thank you
for your call very important question
next one of the behave is can listening
in
looks like Ontario can't welcome to the
program we have just a few minutes
before the break hey there yes I'm here
in your question I'm from Orlando
Orlando hey Ken welcome hey buddy listen
I got a question about the the new
heaven if heavens already perfect why
does the Bible talk about a new heaven
okay you're referring to Revelation
chapter 21 where John says I saw in
new heaven and a new earth for the first
heaven and the first earth was passed
away now when the Bible speaks of heaven
we need to understand there are three
different types of heaven that the Bible
refers to it is the first heaven is what
we call the atmosphere it's where the
birds fly where the clouds float the
second heaven is where the stars are we
can look up at night and we see the
stars that would be the second heaven
the third heaven would be the dwelling
place of God that's where God is so in
Revelation chapter 21 where he says I
saw a new heaven and a new earth the
heaven there is the first heaven it's
referencing the atmosphere surrounding
the earth our atmosphere needs a little
cleaning up with all of the pollution
and all the things that we have done to
it over the years and in the earth made
new not only the earth is recreated but
the atmosphere is recreated as well and
that's why you have that phrase well
thanks for your call - that's an
important question friends you can hear
the music playing in the background it's
not the end of the program we've still
got a number of Bible questions that we
want to get to but we taking a short
break there are some important
announcements that are going to come
your way and then if you have a Bible
question be ready to join us with your
Bible question
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm in six days God created
the heavens and the earth for thousands
of years man has worshiped God on the
seventh day of the week now each week
millions of people worship on the first
day what happened why did God create a
day of rest does it really matter what
day we worship who is behind this great
shift discover the truth behind God's
law and how it was changed visit Sabbath
truth com can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth film
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vor
G
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 7 2 9 7
that'll bring you here to the studio and
again if you don't get through
immediately do hold on we'll try to get
to as many calls as we possibly can in
the next half an hour of our program
we're gonna go to rob who is listening
in Atlanta Rob welcome to the program
you're on the air hey Thank You Sean how
are you tonight doing well good good
good
so so I had a question and relate in
relation to the role that repentance
plays in salvation and to give you a
little context for that question
I see so often now pastors preaching and
talking about you know come come to come
to Jesus accept Jesus as your Savior
it's a free gift it's a free air it's a
free ticket to heaven it's it's all of
those things but then when I read
Matthew Mark in Luke and even up till
probably chapter 14 and John I see so
often the different Jesus this
presenting
to count the cost right - to count the
cost of making him Lord he says things
like why do you called me Lord and do
not do the things that I say see the
parable of the sower the parable of the
talents we see so often where you know
Jesus gives this description is that he
will not be Savior
unless he's also Lord I see so often
pastors from that salvation is you know
he'll be your Savior
without a contemplation of the cause
without looking well you raise it for
good you raise a very good question
and you're right when one comes to
Christ you not only receive His
forgiveness but you also receive his
lordship but the Bible is pretty clear
that there needs to be repentance
associated with forgiveness I'm looking
Acts chapter 2 and verse 38 this is the
Apostle Peter that is patient and he
says repent and let every one of you be
baptized in the name of Jesus Christ for
the remission of your sins and you'll
receive the gift of the Holy Spirit so
Peter says in order for you to receive
the Holy Spirit in order for you to
receive a remission of sins they need to
be repentance now repentance is a
recognition recognition of a sin and a
sorrow for sin if you read a little
earlier in that same chapter in Acts
chapter 2 verse 36 it says after Peter
was preaching it said therefore all the
house of Israel know assuredly that God
has made this Jesus whom you crucified
both Lord and Christ now when they heard
this they were cut to the heart so the
Holy Spirit brought conviction to them
so there needs to be conviction that
leads to repentance repentance then
opens the way for forgiveness but at the
same time we surrender ourselves to
Christ as both our Savior and our Lord
Jesus said why do you call me Lord Lord
and you don't do those things that I
tell you to do he said many in the last
days will say Lord Lord did we not
prophesy in your name and cast out
devils Jesus will say I never knew you
so it's not enough just to claim the
name of Christ we need to claim him as
our Lord and our Savior that's an
important point
thank you so much Sean it's refreshing
to hear somebody state that these days
sometimes you start to think you're
crazy when you when you hear this
repeatedly in the church but you read
something different in the Bible so I
appreciate that clarification and that
gives me great encouragement thank you
you're absolutely on the right track
thanks for your call again just want to
remind those listening we do have a book
that talks about salvation what's
required it's the book that we mentioned
at the top of the program it's called
three steps to heaven we'll be happy to
give that to anybody who calls and asks
the number our resource phone line is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven and again you can just ask
for the book of three it's called three
steps to heaven I'll be happy to send
that to anybody who calls and asks our
next caller that we have is andrew and
is listening from new york
andrew welcome to the program andrew are
you there yes i'm here doing well and
your question this evening yeah I want
to ask a question basically on the
Sabbath I want to know does the fabric
still exist okay a good question we
would one find the Sabbath first mention
in the Bible I seen it in the Old
Testament okay you're on the right track
you got to keep going it's not only in
the beginning and middle of the Old
Testament but you'll find it in the very
second chapter of the first book of the
Old Testament it's first reference in
Genesis 2 where after God created the
earth in six days then he rested on the
seventh day
he's sanctified it he set it apart he
blessed it and then of course the
Sabbath is part of the Ten Commandments
it's the fourth commandment that says
remember the Sabbath day to keep it holy
six days you want to Laban do all your
work but the seventh is the Sabbath of
the LORD thy God and it goes on to say
you shouldn't be doing any work any
secular labor in the Sabbath and then if
you look throughout the Old Testament
God's people kept the Sabbath on the
seventh day at least they were supposed
to they weren't always faithful but it
was always part of God's commandments
Jesus when he was on the earth he kept
the seventh-day Sabbath after Christ's
resurrection and ascension to heaven we
have a number of accounts in the gospel
of that way in the book of Acts of the
early
disciples the early Christians also
keeping the seventh-day Sabbath and then
you go all the way to the last book of
the Bible the book of Revelation where
the Apostle John he was on the island of
Patmos this is somewhere around early 90
80 so this is quite a while after the
Jesus was resurrected 31 ad so this is
90 80 John's an old man says he was in
the spirit on the Lord's Day
so John still recognized the Sabbath has
been the Lord's Day and that's the last
book of the of the New Testament so
throughout the Bible you read about the
Sabbath Revelation chapter 12 verse 17
talks about a group of people at the end
of time who keep the commandments of God
and they have the faith of Jesus as
revelation 14:12 so yes part of the Ten
Commandments is the Sabbath and God
wants us to keep the Sabbath there is a
blessing for those who keep the Sabbath
okay okay the Sabbath is the seventh day
of the week that's what the Bible says
in Exodus chapter 20
now the Bible also tells us which day of
the week Jesus rose from the dead and
what day of the week to Jesus rise from
the dead um we call it Easter Sunday
right
yeah the reservation yes so Jesus rose
from the dead on Sunday the Bible says
Sunday is the first day of the week in
the Gospels so a Sunday is the first day
of the week which day of the week would
be the seventh it would actually be
Saturday which day of the week do Jews
considered to be the Sabbath well it
would be the seventh day which is
Saturday so if you want to go with the
Bible the Sabbath is the seventh day of
the week
it's what today we would commonly refer
to as Saturday and you know it's
interesting if you look back into
Christian history there was an attempt
to try and change the day of worship it
wasn't the most popular day to worship
on the seventh day or Saturday it was
more popular to worship on Sunday and so
there was a gradual Cain change that
came in but there is a rediscovering
amongst Christians
of the Bible Sabbath and the blessings
connected with that so yes the Sabbath
is Saturday it's the seventh day of the
week you know we do have a free book
that we'd be happy to send you on the
subject it's actually one of our amazing
facts study guides and it's called lost
day in history and if you'd call and ask
for that we'll be happy to get that in
the mail right away the number to
receive that is eight hundred eight
thirty five six seven four seven and
again you can just ask for the book or
the study guide called the lost day in
history there is also a website that I'd
highly recommend that you take a look at
it's called Sabbath truths calm for
anyone listening if you're close to your
computer take a look at that video all
at that website it's got a number of
videos dealing with the Sabbath truth I
think you'll find it rather important
our next caller that we have is looks
like we have somebody calling from wait
a minute I'm gonna change calls for just
a moment let's go with mark mark calling
from not quite sure where you have mark
but let's see is there more let's think
yes there sure is they was parked okay
and they haven't had a chance to put
that up on the screen yet but welcome
mark glad you called thank you so much
thanks for having me longtime listener
first-time caller I'm glad you called
thank you so my question for you is I
grew up in a multi-denominational
household and I was curious if you have
any scripture passages that could kind
of guide me in the light as to guide me
in the way of which would be the best
best route to go and understanding more
and discovering my faith okay absolutely
you want to look for a group of
believers that are as close to the Bible
as you could possibly find so I'll just
give you a couple of verses as starting
points and then I'll also reference a
book that I think you might find helpful
probably if you go to any church doesn't
matter what the denomination is and you
ask them well are you the true church
they'll probably say yes but what we
want to know is what does the Bible say
on the subject Revelation chapter 12
verse 17 gives us two characteristics
the true church God's people in the last
days says they keep the commandments as
Revelation chapter 12 verse 17 it says
the dragon was enraged with the woman a
woman in Bible prophecy represents the
church went to make war with the remnant
of her offspring those living near the
end of time and then it says who keep
the commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus so the first
identifying mark of God's people in the
last days is they keep his Commandments
not only six or eight or nine but all
ten of the commandments of so there's a
clue right there it also says they have
the testimony of Jesus or the testimony
of the spirit if you go to revelation
19:10 the Bible tells us that the
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
prophecy so it needs to be a Bible
believing group that believed that the
Bible is inspired they also need to be a
group that Study Bible prophecy as the
spirit guides them and then in
Revelation 14:12 it adds another
characteristic it says they have the
faith of Jesus so you'd want to look for
a church that acknowledges the supremacy
of scripture first and foremost that the
Bible is inspired the Bible is
trustworthy you want to look for a group
of people that keep God's commandments
all of them you want to look for a group
of people who are interested in studying
Bible prophecy they have an
understanding of the Bible truth you
want to look for a group of people that
are led by the Spirit they have the
gifts of the Spirit manifest you want to
understand what those gifts are the
fruit of the Spirit and you want to look
for a group of people that uphold Jesus
as the one who provides forgiveness and
cleansing so these are just a few of
those characteristics that you want to
look for at the bottom line you want to
find a group of people that believe the
truth of the word that's the goal that's
what you're searching for so let me tell
you about a book that we'll be happy to
send you for free it's called the search
for the true church easy name to
remember just the search for the true
church and if you'd call our resource
phone line which is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven as for
the book the search for the true church
we'll be happy to send that to you and
again just compare the
teachings of the different churches with
the Bible and find the church that is
closest to Scripture and you can't go
wrong thank you for your call we
appreciate that mark let's see our next
caller that we have is listening from
Virginia we have Charles Charles welcome
to the program thank you and your
question this evening okay my question
if possible like to have a to course
I'll bide by your policy whatever it may
be well let's start with one and we'll
see if we can squeeze in the second okay
yes okay my my question is in the Book
of Daniel chapter 11 I would like to
know if you can enlighten me on the
identity of the king of the north and
King of the South because of their
importance concerning the last days okay
you're probably looking here at verse
dango chapter 11 starting around verse
40 probably yeah
okay let me just quickly read this for
those who are listening and then we'll
talk a little bit more about it and it
says and at that time all the time let
me read it again at the time of the end
this is verse 40 the King of the South
shall attack him and the king of the
north shall come down against him like a
whirlwind with chariots and horsemen
many ships and he shall enter the
countries overwhelm them and pass
through them he shall all say into the
glorious land and many countries shall
be overthrown but these shall escape
from his hand
Edom Moab and the prominent people of
Ammon and he shall stretch out of his
hand against the countries and even the
land of Egypt and so on and if you read
on to the end of the chapter the next
thing in chapter 12 it talks about
Michael standing up and a terrible time
of trouble we identify that as being the
close of probation so starting in verse
40 these are events that are yet to be
fulfilled I think we nearing that time
period but the full fulfillment of these
verses have not yet been fully revealed
the king of the South has often been
identified as a power that is opposed to
God in referring to atheism or different
religious groups that might be opposed
to God or opposed to Christ in
particular that on recognize him as the
Son of God the king of the north has
been identified often by different Bible
scholars as rare
presenting a religious power it not only
a religious but a religious power that
has political influence or political
Peretz sometimes identified as the beast
power revelation 13 or the Antichrist
power so there is a big showdown that
occurs right close to the close of
probation and the second coming of
Christ so I don't have time to get into
all the details it's a very detailed
study if you look through chapter 11 it
deals with a lot of details but starting
over from verse 40 onwards it's talking
about the time of the end it's referring
to the time that I think we're entering
into now when these things will be
revealed it'll be a lot clearer once
they begin to be fulfilled so I don't
leave that helps a little bit but king
of the north has been identified as a
political power that has religious
connections and the king of the south
has been identified as those powers that
are opposed to Christ opposed to the
teachings of Christ and there's the
showdown right at the end you know
suppose you could see that also in the
image of the the one that you know the
statute I had a gold yes in a peak of
separating between the iron and also the
the clay clay yes and then the stone
that strikes it said brings you right up
till the second coming of Christ it's a
good point good observation there you
said yet another question let's try and
squeeze that in I would like to know is
can the way Addie baptized okay
can the lady in the church baptize well
when you look in the Bible baptism
typically not only involves the person
committing their life to Christ but it
also involves fellowship with a church
body the verse that we read in Acts
chapter 2 where it talks about the
people Peter said repent and be baptized
and it says they were baptized and God
added to the church those who have been
saved so baptism is one our commitment
to Christ but it's also our connection
with his church so typically in the
church those who are recognized as the
leadership of the church are the ones
that would perform the baptism so in my
church it's usually the pastor's that do
the baptisms in some cases it is local
church
in the absence of the past they can do
the baptism it's rather important
however that prior to a person being
baptized that they are instructed in the
word they need to know what decision
actually making and what it means to be
baptized so and what it means to be a
part of a church how do they get
involved so there is some instruction
that's needed and usually the pastor of
the church or one of the elders the
leadership are the ones that lead adding
baptism and thank you for the knowledge
all right well thank you for your call
we appreciate that Charles and we're
gonna go to our next caller the behalf I
think we have let's see we have David
and David I'm not exactly sure where
you're listening but is there a David
out there David going once going twice
alright we gonna try Jason next and
let's see Jason from Compton California
Jason welcome to the program all right
thanks for polling yeah Jason nice to
meet you you have a nice program going
on and you know I'm all for it well
thanks for wearing absolutely hey Jason
let me ask you do you have your radio on
in the background I hear a little bit of
an echo just turn that down no problem
otherwise it was torched the mission
that Jesus have went on the Sea of
Galilee yes when he crossed the sea to
to go to the Ellen he came across the
demons yes the demon-possessed man yes
so my being is that and the Bible says
that it was still called the Sea of
Galilee right yes but you know Mike
where neither your research that it was
it's uh you know
in salt water so I find that the Sea of
Galilee was really a leak yes you're
correct yes you're correct yeah don't be
thrown out by the name see if we
actually know the location of it it's
the sea of gathered all it the sea of
galilee it's a large lake in the
northern part of Israel and there were a
number of fishing villages in the area
Capernaum was right there by the Sea of
Galilee it's not a salt body of water
the the salt sea or the Dead Sea is in
the southern part of Israel but the Sea
of Galilee they called it the sea was in
the northern area that was the name
there is another name that's also
referenced in the Bible called
kanessa at the sea of Ganesa at or close
to the Nazareth but that was the name
that they call it okay you know how they
said that the spirits wanted to the
swine into me they went into the B jump
off the cliff right into the into the
water yep well there is no well you know
there is if it's if over on the side
that the call can answer it yeah let me
if you can just kind of visualize it if
you've seen the map of Israel the Sea of
Galilee is on the northern part on the
let me see the western part of the Sea
of Galilee that's the more fruitful
plane but over - especially in the time
of Christ on the eastern side of the Sea
of Galilee that was going right up
against the desert and they were cliffs
in that area that went down into the sea
and there were people that lived on that
side of the Sea of Galilee who were not
Jews sort of a mixed group of people
that stayed on that side and for that
reason they had pigs because pigs are
unclean for Jews so Jesus when he
crossed over the Sea of Galilee he went
from the area that was mostly populated
by Jews across to the other side where
there are a number of other groups that
were and that's where he met the man
with the unclean spirits that came out
from the caves and the tombs so actually
that is in the air
yeah so there were Jews that kept pigs
why no the Jews didn't but there were
others who were not Jews that lived on
that side of the lake and they were the
ones that were hurting the pigs
so yeah they the Jews wouldn't keep the
pigs
it was the Gentiles there in that area
the Palestinians at that time my
research and I kind of miscalculated you
know I felt like he went across the
Mediterranean ocean B now we know during
that time like you know what what storm
you know that will be so power enough to
cause big waves
sure well it is interesting that because
of the geography of the place you've got
a lot of desert area to the east of the
Sea of Galilee it was quite common to
have these hot winds blowing down from
the east side of the sea down onto the
Sea of Galilee and clashing with the the
cooler air on the east and they would
often be some rather violent storms that
would occur on the Sea of Galilee so it
was not uncommon to have these type of
sudden thunderstorms that would occur in
that region good question
appreciate you calling and asking about
that are we going to go to our next
caller which is not listening in
Michigan no welcome to the program thank
you so very much
I am a longtime listener and a
first-time caller we appreciate you
calling in and my Bible question is in
Esther when they were going to kill all
of all of the Jews they fasted my
daughter is going to have brain surgery
on Tuesday and my question is why do
people fast is it to tease God into
doing what we wanted to do or you know I
wouldn't be proper for me to fast for my
daughter okay
very good question
I'm gonna move right into the answer
because we got two minutes left and I
don't want to run out of time because
this is an important question the reason
the Bible speaks of fasting isn't to try
and change God's mind it's not as if God
doesn't want to answer our prayer Jesus
said God is more willing to give good
gifts to his children than we as parents
are willing to give gifts to good gifts
to our children the purpose of fasting
is to set aside anything that might
distract our focus or our faith from God
so fasting is saying Lord this is so
important that I want to lay aside
anything that would distract and set my
my attention and my focus on you
and seeking your will in this situation
praying a special way for your guidance
there are some benefits to fasting where
it does allow a clearing of the mind
it's almost laying aside something that
we like saying Lord this is so important
I'm going to lay this aside because I
really want your blessing
I recognize your blessing is even more
important than my food so is it
appropriate to fast if somebody is
facing some physical difficulty or
surgery as you mentioned in your case
yes it's appropriate to fast their
different degrees of fasting there is
not eating which is probably the common
one there is fasting where someone might
skip a meal or two you can fast for a
day you can fast for 3-4 days fast for a
week depending upon the person's health
of course there are some folks where it
might not be wise for them to fast
because of blood sugars and some other
things and that needs to also be taken
into consideration but no the bible does
speak of fasting and there is a correct
kind of fast well friends you hear the
sound of the music in the background we
want to thank you for all of your Bible
questions today if we didn't get to your
question give us a call again next week
when once again we'll take Bible answers
until then god bless take a look at our
website amazing facts dot o-r-g
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before tune in
next time for more Bible answers live
honest and accurate answers to your
Bible questions life's a curious thing I
mean just when things seem under control
with something new your marriage your
job your health you could look to the
stars
but they don't know the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts
it's 27 personal study guides leave you
on a life-changing journey get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
find out what the critics are raving
about top scholars and theologians from
around the country come together to
reveal the hidden history of the book of
Revelation with powerful reenactments
and incredible visual effects this 95
minute masterpiece brings to life the
book of Revelation like never before
revelation is no longer a mystery get
your copy today visit iTunes or AF
bookstore calm
can't get enough amazing facts Bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge
24 hours a day seven days a week right
from your computer or mobile device
visit aft vor G did you know that Noah
was present at the birth of Abraham okay
maybe he wasn't in the room but he was
alive and probably telling stories about
his floating zoo from the creation of
the world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the bible and draw closer
to God's Word
go deeper visit Bible History com if
you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word visit our website at WWE
you